If I hadn't been the victim of this earthquake, I would have lived here now.
Well, because
I had this day, this day is because I
had a nuclear accident six years later in 2005.  It's left. It
's the same as the calendar 5 years ago. I haven't eaten since March 11th. At
first glance, it looks like there was nothing, but this is the instrument or my
wife's house.  It was a store of Aizu lacquerware, so I brought it with a wedding tool
. I like it, but I haven't used it even once.
That kind of thing is exactly what love Ricky is stuffed into there.
[Music]
I feel like I've been bathed in sweets
.
[Music]
[Music
] I have the abolition of nuclear power after the nuclear power plant is abolished. Because of the smell,
writing about nuclear power and its cleaning is all destroyed together.
It's the same in the sense that everything is taken away in an instant.
I feel the powerlessness of human beings who can't do anything.
I can't do anything with radiation that can't do
anything.  I don't feel like using it because it's contaminated
[Music]
I think that if we don't catch it, there's probably no next Yamato era.
I think it's something to think about
me
[music]